les européens qui sont
théoriquement encore engagé au mali
d'ailleurs il ya sept ce sommet ua
aujourd'hui à bruxelles avec une
quarantaine de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui sont présents c'est
dire l'importance de ce rendez vous que
vous couvrez caroline de camaret
j'espère vous êtes avec nous pour
france24 bonjour caroline je crois que
les dirigeants commencent tard arrivée à
bruxelles ils ont en tête ce retrait du
mali emmanuel macron a visiblement voulu
associer les européens à cette décision
oui tout à fait c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui c'était quand même un coup
de tonnerre avant le démarrage de ce
sommet avec 80 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ne sont conviés que les
africains n'ont putschistes à ce sommet
et il fallait pour emmanuel macron et
bien avant avant ce rendez vous quand
même très important de deux jours assuré
que l'opération barkan qui prend fin
peut conserver l'esprit de ta quoi parce
que souvenez que quand en 2013 les
français se sont engagés au mali il
était seul trait seuls ils se sont senti
très seul longtemps et on l'entend voulu
rallier leurs partenaires européens en
disant que finalement c'était la sphère
de toute l'europe que la lutte contre le
terrorisme alors en 2020 ils ont monté
cette force takouba qui compte
aujourd'hui 800 hommes par exemple la
république tchèque a mis au pot 150
hommes et trois avions enfin il y a tout
de même 13 pays européen autres que la
france engagé et effectivement depuis
que les français ne sont pas les
bienvenus au mali et bien les autres non
plus le contingent danois rappelez vous
il ya quelques semaines a été rejetée du
mali par la junte et les danois ont été
très vexé à tel point qu'ils ont retiré
leur aide humanitaire de 40 milliards
d'euros donc aux eaux
ce mali or l'aide humanitaire représente
30% du budget du mali et les européens
sont très présents financièrement
d'ailleurs sur ce sahel qu'il faut
arrachée aux griffes du terrorisme avec
un budget de 8,5 milliards d'euros qui a
été décidée pour les sept prochaines
années dans cette région du sahel mais
il n'empêche c'est à un coup dur pour
emmanuel macron qui finalement vous les
avez réussi à entraîner un certain
nombre d'européens dans un un embryon de
défense européenne la défense européenne
une boule sol stratégique pour les
européens c'est véritablement ce qu'il
veut promouvoir lors de sa présidence
française du conseil de l'union
européenne lors de ce premier semestre
et c'est un coup dur mais en même temps
ça a été un coup dur je trouve quand
même qui a été plutôt bien organisé du
point de vue de la communication puisque
il a figuré à côté du chef de file de
l'union africaine macky sall de la
cedeao et aussi de cher michel pour dire
que lui il avait ce retrait consulter
tout le monde les européens les
africains pas comme en afghanistan où
les américains finalement n'avait pas
parlé aux européens non ça a été quelque
chose de consulter c'est quelque chose
que l'on va construire ce retrait est la
force takouba ne se retire pas d'afrique
non elle va être dispatchés